a whistleblower has come forward ready
to blow the lid
off of years and years of biden family
corruption
man's name is tony bob yelinski
he was a business partner of hunter
biden
he recorded a phone call with rob walker
rob walker
is a self-described biden family
representative he's the husband of joe
biden's former top
white house aide and the there is are a
lot of
aspects to this smoking gun this
whistleblower
but here rob walker the biden family
representative
says that if this whistleblower comes
forward he's going to bury him all
if he doesn't come out on record
i am providing the fact that you're just
gonna tell me just bury all of this man
will the whistleblower bury all of the
bidens
will this scandal finally undo joe
will it even matter at all does this
even matter at all to voters
we will find out i'm michael knowles
this michael knowles show
[Music]
is this whistleblower going to be the
decisive october surprise
or is it just more talk talk talk
well you know if you want to talk very
well you got to go check out puretalk
usa
black friday cyber monday there is a one
day only sale wouldn't you rather just
work with a company
who puts you on a pedestal every single
day that is what you get with pure talk
a veteran-run wireless company who
understands what it means to serve
verizon
att t-mobile if you're with them you are
overpaying
pure and simple pure talk can easily
save you 400 bucks a year listen
all you need unlimited talk text two
gigs of data you get that for 20 bucks a
month
and if you go over on your data usage
they don't charge you for it i know what
you're thinking you're saying i like
being
with att verizon or t-mobile right i'm
telling you you can get the exact same
network and i'm not saying
that you can get a similar network you
get a similar i'm saying
the exact same one stop overpaying grab
your mobile phone
dial pound 250 say michael knowles
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s
when you do you will save 50 off your
first month they'll pound 2-5-0
say keyword michael knowles pure talk is
simply smarter wireless pound two five
zero
and say my name you can thank me later
you know my favorite comment from
yesterday thomas eggelhoff says
kamalahara sounds like joaquin phoenix's
joker specifically
at first she sounds like she's about to
cry and all of a sudden she bursts into
laughter
oh man i actually hadn't thought of that
before but
once you see that you can't unsee that
any time in an interview that she gets
any question other than
kamala why are you so beautiful any
question that requires her to think at
all
she gets very shaky and nervous you saw
this yesterday when she was asked
what her perspective is and she said uh
and then she went right to identity
politics uh my perspective is a
a black woman an uh immigrant and a
woman and uh
and just it didn't and then she bursts
into the bizarre laughter so yes i guess
kamala is
the joker very scary stuff especially
because joe biden seems to be on the
ropes
tucker carlson got this interview
yesterday with a whistleblower because
of course he did because tucker gets all
of these great scoops on cable tv
this is this is not tucker's former
business partner this is hunter's former
business partner tony
bob yalinski uh tony
has has said that he has had
conversations with the biden family
with jim biden in particular that's joe
biden's brother
obviously with hunter biden apparently
jim biden said that joe knows about all
the corruption
but he has plausible deniability so
he'll get away with it
i'm thinking about the biden family like
how are they
doing this i know joe decided not to run
in 2016 but what if he ran in the future
aren't they taking political risk or
headline risk
and i remember looking at jim biden and
saying how are you guys
getting away with this like or aren't
you concerned
and he sort of looked at me and he
laughed a little bit and said
plausible deniability he said that out
loud
uh yes he said it directly to me
one-on-one in a cabana at the peninsula
hotel
after about a you know hour and a half
two-hour meeting with me
asking out of concern how are you guys
doing this aren't you
concerned that you're gonna put your
brother's you know future presidential
campaign at risk
um you know the chinese the stuff that
you guys have been doing already in 2015
and 2016 around the world
and uh i just can almost picture his
face where he sort of chuckles and says
you know plausible deniability plausible
deniability well
i think that's probably true now you do
have to ask yourself okay why is this
whistleblower
coming forward does he have some beef
with
hunter biden i think hunter biden
probably has a beef with a lot of people
because hunter biden behaves like a
degenerate
so it could be maybe he doesn't like joe
biden now maybe
who knows why he's he's turned on the
biden family but he's
he's acknowledging the years of
corruption that that we
have seen hints of before and then he
gets specific he gets specific
on the geopolitical adversary that we're
all so worried about these days
china and and tony comes out and says
joe biden
effectively is owned by china
the chinese and cfc uh never viewed me
i'm
insignificant and irrelevant in this
discussion to them it was always the
biden family
it wasn't hunter biden it wasn't jim
biden it was the biden family
who's obviously led and um and operated
by joe biden
and in a document that you guys have and
i think has been provided
to you know to the world the chinese
reference
that because of their trust in the biden
family the chairman ye and director
zhang
are excited about moving forward in this
and in that document they reference
loaning five million dollars to the bd
family
right the bd family is the biden family
and notice they didn't say we're loaning
that money to oneida holdings
or we're loaning that money to tony
babalinsky we're loaning that money to
james gillier or rob walker
they once again not a document generated
by me a document
generated by cfc that they're loaning
that money to the biden
family so i think joe biden and the
biden family are compromised
i think all of that is true so is this
the big shocking revelation
less than two weeks until the election
that's going to undo joe biden
no i don't think so i don't think so
what new information is being presented
here we're getting more evidence that
joe biden is corrupt so that's good
because we are seeing ties not just
between hunter biden and some corrupt
people
but james biden not just james biden but
joe biden and we already knew this
because
hunter biden doesn't have any skills so
of course the only reason he would be
hired and paid
by these foreign oligarchs is to get
access to his dad
he denied that he gave access to his dad
now these emails have come out and said
yes he did give access to his dad
yes he these people did meet with his
dad yes his dad is a big crook
so what we already knew that i look i
wish that i could be as excited as
everybody else is over these revelations
i just think it's baked into the cake do
you think any biden voter
is going to change his vote now because
these revelations have come out
i don't think so biden's been a crook
politician for 50 years
do we really do we really think now
they're going to say oh well i knew he
was a crook for 50 years but
you know now he's getting money from
china okay we've got to switch our votes
maybe a little bit on the periphery but
i actually i don't think
this is going to matter too much i think
the one effect this could have on the
race
is it could motivate conservatives i i
was talking to senator cruz about this
yesterday on our show verdict
there are two kinds of of campaigns
there are the persuasion campaigns and
there are the get out the vote campaigns
right there's the one where you want to
win over people in the middle
the other is where you want to turn out
your own base this is emphatically the
latter
everyone has had a strong opinion on
donald trump since the 80s okay nobody
is undecided here
so it's all about getting out the vote
part of the reason why the left always
pushes negative polls
is to demoralize conservatives so we
don't show up to the polls and then they
can win before anyone had to go out and
actually vote
so if we've got the kind of evidence
that hunter biden is corrupt
it could have the effect of getting us
more and more excited about this
thinking there's a chance joe biden
doesn't doesn't win the race
you know thinking the biden family is
collapsing and going and voting if it
has that effect i'm happy
but i don't think we need to focus too
much on this i think we need to focus
more
on the absolute disaster joe biden would
be for this country
and the fact that the guy can barely
finish an english sentence
joe biden this is unheard of in in
modern
presidential politics joe biden has
effectively
sworn that he won't campaign anymore for
the last two weeks
of this race that's very strange he
thinks he's in a good position he thinks
the polls are behind him
so he's just going to stay at home so he
doesn't give himself the opportunity
to screw up any more than he already has
nobody is trying to get him to show up
out of the mainstream media
out of the democratic establishment the
only guy who is trolling biden into
getting back onto the campaign trail
is the master troll in chief president
trump who says that joe biden
has basically given up on life
no no he has he's waved a white flag on
life
he doesn't leave his basement joe
biden's been accusing trump of waving
the white flag of coronavirus
surrendering on coronavirus he said no
i'm not doing that
joe biden's waving a white flag he's
waving a white flag on life because he
knows that if he goes out and he talks
and he says hello to anybody
he's going to screw up so he's hiding in
his basement right after trump says this
what happens joe biden decides to come
out of hiding
i'm i'm not sure that this corruption
stuff
it really matters but biden is hiding
anyway because he doesn't want to have
to answer questions on hunter
he doesn't want to have to answer
questions on
on any of these other people so joe
biden shows up
and he's at a campaign event they've got
a band there and he's going to go give a
speech
you've seen the trump rallies you've
seen what 20 000 people there 30 000
people there sometimes
and then you see the biden rally joe
biden shows up the band is playing there
were probably
18 people in the room he walks down the
stairs
they're playing midnight train to
georgia which is kind of a depressing
song
to be playing during a campaign right
because it's all about a guy who failed
l.a was too much for the man and so he's
living the life he's come to know
biden's got his little circles there i
don't even know if it's 18 people it's
not it's not even 18. it's probably
a dozen people okay a little bit more on
the side so okay
18 people you got probably more staff
there than guests
and he's he's old so it's taking him
forever to walk to the stage
he's trying to run a little bit but
that's awkward
handful of claps
he's leaving he is leaving on that
midnight train
i know that the polls say that biden is
way up maybe biden is way up maybe
biden's gonna win maybe it's gonna be a
blowout for joe biden
but you've got to admit it's kind of
weird that trump gets
tens of thousands of people to show up
to his rallies and joe biden can't get
20 people to show up to his rallies
you got to admit that is kind of weird
i've never seen enthusiasm so skewed
in a race where the poles are so tight
what does that mean does that mean the
poles are wrong does that mean that libs
are so afraid that they're just staying
in their homes
because they're afraid of the flu what
is it what does that really mean
does it mean that they just got the time
wrong on
joe biden's rally well they should have
worn a movement watch movement watches
are all about looking good
while keeping it simple okay they don't
tell you how many steps you've taken
they don't tell you how fast your heart
is beating and how you slept
they don't do that you know what they do
like watches are supposed to do they
tell the time that's it they tell the
time like true classic timepieces
and you look good while you're wearing
them movement was a crowdfunded startup
it's it's kind of hard to even remember
that now because it's such a popular
watchprint
crowdfunded startup they they did very
very well
as a crowdfunded startup now they're one
of the biggest watch brands in the world
okay they wanted real quality products
for everyone started by two college
dropouts now they have almost two
million watches sold
in over 160 countries i've been wearing
movement watches for
years now they were one of the earliest
sponsors on this show and they start at
just
95 bucks okay you would be looking at
400
500 for the same quality from a
traditional brand in a department store
get 15 percent off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement
dot com slash knowles k wlas i recommend
the revolver line i think that one is
super cool
and the arc automatic also great i have
both of those watches they're super
super cool movements launching new
styles on their site all the time
check out their latest at mvmt.com go to
knowles kw mvmt.com and join the
movement
so biden can't muster any of these
people to actually show up
i think this matters much more than the
corruption i think we got to focus on
how there's no enthusiasm why there's no
enthusiasm what his plans will mean for
the country for the economy what his
plans will mean
socially what his plans will mean for
the structure of our government court
packing
and what his cognitive issues mean
for the presidency joe biden was asked
one of these events he was asked about
amy barrett
and this should be a slam dunk this is
one of the
top issues on the entire campaign the
supreme court and this confirmation that
just happened a couple of days ago
joe biden he couldn't seem to string the
thoughts together
here's the deal one of the things that
that is important
is that um
keep in mind although they're going to
vote on
uh uh
that is so embarrassing it's
embarrassing for joe it's embarrassing
for the campaign
senator tell us about amy barrett okay
well here's the deal the thing about it
is
uh they're gonna vote today or is it
yesterday or they're gonna uh
uh who and i actually i don't even wanna
make fun of him for it anybody who's had
aged friends or relatives knows this
happens
you know it's a senior moment except
with joey has senior moments all of the
time
don't begrudge him that you know it's
going to happen to all of us probably
someday if we live that long
but it doesn't mean that you should be
president while you're having those
issues
if you cannot give an opinion on the
supreme court confirmation
that just happened you should not be
president you don't have the stamina
to do it and his campaign staff knows it
we've been seeing this for months and
months in the mainstream media are
denying it
where joe will start trying to talk to
the press and he'll start rambling
and they will take him by the arm and
lead him away
like come here come here old grandpa so
come here come here old joe you know
let's go we're gonna again if
if joe were just their grandpa perfectly
fine a lovely interaction but he's not
he's trying to be president
barrett today is sort of okay bye and
just leads them away and the press won't
ask a question about it
because the press or campaign operatives
for
for biden now some of the biden gaffes
have been
a little bit funnier maybe they're
freudian slips i don't know
just yesterday joe biden was talking
about uh
about his wife and then kamala harris
and kamala's wife
but my wife jill as you know and doug
imhoff uh
commonly his wife are there common will
be back uh later this week i think on
friday
that may have been a freudian slip which
is obviously where you say one thing but
me and your mother
so joe talks about commonly wife he
meant to say her husband i guess
those issues i know it's
counterintuitive but i think those
issues are going to matter much more
here's my evidence we've known about the
joe biden corruption stuff
well we've known about it for many years
but in the campaign this has been
a hot topic of discussion for at least
six eight months
didn't skew anything remember after that
first debate
trump was going really hard at biden
actually probably helped biden in the
debate
that second debate did not go as well
for joe biden
actually right after the second debate
one of the big trends that took place on
google was
can i change my vote
well why why was that it's because joe
biden and the moderator and the
entire established presidential debate
commission forced
joe biden to have to finish his
sentences it was actually a
miscalculation
they thought they were helping biden by
doing it but it didn't help biden so
he had to finish the sentences and he
seemed weak and he didn't have an answer
and he seemed a little bit radical but
more than that he seemed like he wasn't
all there
so people asked can i change my vote now
this is very difficult
because 62 million votes have already
been cast
people have already voted this is a big
problem with early voting early voting
should not exist
absentee ballots should exist in very
limited circumstances where you solicit
ballot but otherwise you should vote
on election day there are a lot of
shenanigans that go on we've already
heard about a lot of shenanigans out of
philly out of new york out of new jersey
places where people are messing around a
little bit sometimes with the votes
you find a box of ballots on the side of
the road in some places
election security is very difficult
campaigns have election security on
election day but you can't have election
security for two months
and also we're in a campaign campaigns
are about persuading people new things
happen
you time your campaigns for how it's
going to affect election day
we should only have election day with
some absentee ballots in limited
circumstances
because now people want to undo their
votes
can they do it in some places they can
so this is worth i i
suspect if you're listening to this show
you're not having second thoughts you
know you didn't vote for joe and then
now you're
you're considering switching maybe
though maybe we do have a number of
democrats and left-wingers who listen to
this show so maybe i've changed your
mind if you happen to live in
new york florida arizona pennsylvania
michigan minnesota wisconsin
washington mississippi idaho and
connecticut you may be able to amend
your vote there are different rules in
all of those places
if you live in any of those states if
your loved ones live in any of those
states and they want to change their
vote
they sometimes can but they've got to
act
early and then in the future i think we
need to get rid of this early voting
entirely
because it is unfair to people it is
unfair to the candidates and it is
open to fraud but i suspect
there are going to be a lot of changes
to our system
after this presidential race because if
the democrats when they've already told
us they're going to try to add two more
states
puerto rico and washington dc they're
going to try to get rid of the electoral
college
they're going to try to pack the supreme
court i mean we're talking about major
changes
some people believe that and this has
been
an explicit pitch of the joe biden
campaign they believe if joe biden gets
elected
things go back to normal if if trump
gets elected if he gets re-elected
then they're going to keep burning down
the cities and things are going to get
worse and worse and worse and joe biden
with a
not so veiled threat says we can't take
four more years of this
meaning we can't take four more years of
the city's being burned down so vote for
me
you know sure as a nice country you have
there would be a would be a shame if
something happened to it
but i don't think things are going to
get better if joe biden gets elected i'm
not even convinced that they're going to
lift the coronavirus restrictions
that's always been a joke too we've said
november 4th they're going to cure
coronavirus maybe or maybe they just
took a lot of power and they're going to
keep it
think about if you're a conservative
think about how
brutal the obama ears were the obama
years were
obama's ears are also brutal no the the
obama years
were very tough for us because he would
just stick his finger in our
eye all the time and he would he would
talk about the right side of history and
how we were bitter clingers and he used
the irs to
to mess up our non-profit organizations
he would just poke his finger in her
it was very annoying i think we have to
admit
trump has done the same to the the left
he hasn't committed the crimes that the
left committed you know abusing the
federal government spying on his
opponents he hasn't he actually hasn't
done that
but from a rhetorical standpoint he has
done that and they
are going to be out for blood and they
are so
furious that trump was elected in the
first place they refused to accept that
it was legitimate
but they're so furious they are going to
ratchet
up the level of national tension it will
not go down
the the most persuasive pitch of the
biden campaign is return to normalcy
we're not returning to normal no matter
who wins this election we're not
returning to normal there will be
major major political battles that will
cut to
the core of our constitutional
government and
unfortunately there might be more what's
the euphemism
civil unrest you've seen it now for
months and months and months that's why
you've got to know how to protect
yourself
personal defense network pdn is an
educational community
built by patriots just like you that
provides vital easy to understand real
world tips techniques and tactics
the pdn team has the world's best
instructors and they've been delivering
life-saving information to people like
you
for over 15 years learn how to keep
yourself and your loved ones
safe all of pdn's contributors are
active educators
they know what they're talking about
they teach life-saving skills to
military personnel
law enforcement people just like you all
around the world you may be the last
line of defense when that
evil comes calling so it is never too
soon to be prepared i'm
i'm really thrilled about pdm
because look i like going out shooting
guns and i've
i've done a little uh little type of
personal defense training before
they call it krav maga i call it krav
maga in in my
being a conservative american that's so
you know so i've done some of these
things but i'm not that good at it i
don't really know how to
how to use these personal defense
techniques all that well
so i love having these personal
instructors
that can be beamed right in uh through
my screen so i can
i can learn it in uh in my own comfort
and then put those tactics into use
go to myrightsmyhome.com michael
the discount will automatically apply at
checkout because you're a listener of
ours
their premium membership will only cost
three dollars for the first full year
three dollars normally sells for 69
bucks
go to myrightsmyhome.com michael the
discount will automatically apply at
checkout and the way things are going
never too soon to go to go check them
out
i think there are big changes coming
around you've even seen this language
from the left in recent
in recent days they've talked about the
green new deal
right then evoking the new deal is
evoking franklin delano roosevelt
the new deal was a major some say
irreversible structural change to our
constitutional order
you've heard about court packing that's
actually another idea that came from fdr
you've heard about lots of other major
changes well
the lincoln project the lincoln project
is out with a
a very scary commercial well you know
the lincoln project or a bunch of these
con artists unemployed ex-republican
operatives
and campaign consultants so they're
they're raising a lot of money from
left-wingers
and they've aired this commercial with a
big fear that if president trump gets
re-elected
he might never give up power
[Applause]
[Music]
ohio florida they all just started
falling in line
hey honey
[Applause]
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump trump won
but i thought you could only be
president two times
[Applause]
not anymore
[Applause]
the lincoln project is responsible for
the content
of course the lincoln project is
responsible now there is a real irony
here
which is these left wingers and i
include the lincoln project
among them we're talking about how we
need
a new deal like fdr gave us how we need
to pack the courts like fdr tried to do
and we need to be very afraid of trump
running for a third term
like wait for it fdr did
also ran for a fourth term actually the
only way we got rid of that american
monarch was because he died in office
finally and then they passed a
constitutional amendment to stop people
from doing that
every president before fdr had followed
george washington's example
and not served more than two terms
except for fdr the american monarch the
one that the left wants to go back to
this is what the left does they always
always project
i mean i got to tell you that commercial
got me really excited for trump's third
term i just
i don't think he's willing to do it i
want him to go in like charles ii
and say congress you are dissolved go
home
i am the emperor it's not going to
happen not going to happen sorry guys
sorry lincoln project
now the lincoln project none of them
actually believe that's going to happen
the lincoln project is the most
dishonest hack movement in politics that
i've seen
in my lifetime okay it is just
pure grift i know that word gets abused
a lot these days grift and grifter
it means con artist and it's basically
used
to to apply to anyone that you disagree
with that's how it's become
popular but there is a specific use of
this and the specific use applies to the
lincoln project they are con
artists they don't believe anything the
reason they started the lincoln project
is because they were out of
work gop campaign consultants
who couldn't get hired anymore because
it was trump's party now and he kicked
all of them out
so they gave up all of their principles
and became democrats
if they had any principles in the first
place and they
a lot of them were in debt some of them
were in were lobbyists for russia i mean
these
these are corrupt dudes who've been
working in politics
for a very long time so they just air a
bunch of nonsense but the way it works
actually my kind of defense of the
lincoln project
and why i think some conservatives
should come around to it is all the
lincoln project is doing
is lining the pockets of these
unemployable campaign consultants
by milking democrats so it is it the
lincoln project is a wealth
dis redistribution scheme to take idiot
gullible democrats money and give it to
unemployed
gop campaign consultants give you
another example they just put
a couple billboards up in times square
jared kushner saying
new yorkers are going to suffer and
that's their problem
and this is a quote obviously taken way
out of context from from jared kushner
and then it's next to one of ivanka who
i don't know why ivanka's on the
on the billboard but it says 33 000 new
yorkers dead
224 000 dead americans
like that's ivanka's fault like ivanka
killed them also
what if the if the number of new yorkers
dead is so disproportionate to the
number of americans
maybe that's not the trump's fault maybe
that's the fault of
andrew cuomo the governor of new york or
bill de blasio the mayor of new york
right i don't know why that would become
the republicans but it actually doesn't
matter
why are there billboards up in new york
why is a
a campaign organization that is
dedicated to
kicking trump out of office why are they
spending their money a lot of money
on billboards in new york trump's not
going to win new york
it's not a battleground state that's a
that's a democrat state
the reason they're doing that is so that
they can advertise for the lincoln
project
and get more money they've been doing
this on morning joe nobody watches
morning joe except for
gullible leftists who are likely to give
money
to leftist organizations so they've been
running advertisements on morning joe in
washington dc
people aren't going to vote for donald
they're going to their washington dc is
taxation without representation to begin
with
but they're not going to vote for trump
you know even even if they were to play
a significant role in the presidential
election
they're not going to vote for trump
there it's just a way of taking money
from democrats and that's totally fine
by me it's kind of funny
i almost respect these con artists a
little bit more than the crazy people
because there are these
these hacks like the lincoln project and
then there are people who
genuinely believe this stuff that
they're putting out there
there's one video in particular a woman
crying in her bathtub over trump that
is not even over trump over amy coney
barrett that
is uh really a work of performance art
you know the presidential election is
almost here it's i can't believe how
close it is
we have an amazing day of programming
for you our live stream starts on
tuesday november 3rd at 3 p.m eastern
12 p.m noon pacific features special
guests live interviews and more leading
up to a very special episode
of backstage where we will be covering
the results with you in real time and
even better join daily wire now get 25
off with code
election so you can watch all of our
election coverage live
with our apple tv and roku apps so watch
the election with us at dailywire.com
get 25 off your daily wire membership
with code election when you sign up
today head on over
sign up go to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
welcome back you've seen these videos
it's a genre video that i don't really
understand which is
hysterical women filming themselves
crying
i don't know i don't cry all that much
not saying that to brag you know i'm not
saying that to be
macho here but i just i don't cry a lot
you know only if a dear beloved family
member dies or if i see a particularly
gorgeous sunset and one tear just
wistfully kind of falls down my cheek
but but i will say this
when i have cried i do not have the
impulse
to film myself and then post it on tik
tok
i don't maybe i'm an old fuddy duddy
maybe i'm a boomer i don't have that
impulse
but a lot of these left-wing women do
one
crazy lady decided to film herself in a
bathtub
weeping because a new justice was added
to the supreme court
don't mind me i'm in the bath but
while i've been here i got a
notification
that that uh
amy coney parent was
officially converted to the supreme
court
i didn't think i would be this affected
by it
but i'm scared i'm scared for me
other women people
who need help everyone except white men
so um please vote next week
let's try to do something yeah man white
men are terrible you know i hate those
guys because of their sex and their race
you know that's what makes me hate them
so much because they're so bad
all the other people are so much better
you know isn't that
that's that is what they believe this is
even this like silly frivolous
white liberal woman why is she afraid
what is she scared of i guess the only
right of hers that amy barrett is
threatening that a conservative court
would threaten is the right to kill her
child through abortion but let's say
worst case scenario for this lady let's
say roe versus wade is overturned
that seems like an unlikely scenario but
if it were then
in almost certainly the issue would go
to the states i assume this crazy lady
lives
in a state that would permit abortion so
she still gets to kill her kid
let's say she doesn't let's say she
lives in the middle of alabama or
something
and so the state is actually going to
outlaw abortion
if roe versus wake gets overturned what
does that mean for what is she so afraid
of it means that she won't be able to
kill her kid
and she'll have to you know have the kid
for if she does become pregnant if
her contraception doesn't work or
something she's going to be
uncomfortable for nine months and then
give the kid up for adoption
or raise the kid if she wants to that's
it that's what she's afraid of
that's the great fear that has her
cowering crying in a bathtub
is not being able to kill her
hypothetical child
maybe in a very unlikely circumstance
that is a mania that is hysteria
this woman needs help she needs a
support network
i would say she should talk to her
husband something tells me though maybe
that's not a possibility
when society breaks down when
the sense of family most importantly the
basic building block of society but also
local
government civic institutions the church
your bowling league your township your
what your state whatever when
all those things break down you are left
as an atomized individual and the only
meaningful relationship that you can
have is with the federal government
so like if this let's say this woman
were married and her husband came home
and cheated on her or you know i don't
know
did sold bet the family farm or whatever
did something
that action would merit that reaction
that is the reaction of a
personal affront in an intimate
relationship
but this woman's reaction makes it
appear that her most intimate personal
relationship is with the federal
government
which i think it probably is barack
obama pitched this as part of his
re-election campaign in 2012. he called
it the life of julia you now can barely
find it on the internet it was basically
scrubbed from the internet it described
a woman named julia this hypothetical
woman
from cradle to grave having everything
provided for her
by the federal government no husband no
family
no local community no nothing at one
point she chooses to have a child
doesn't get married doesn't fall in love
doesn't go on nope just chooses to have
a child
and then big daddy obama federal
government will come in
and provide for her and then she dies
and she dies alone and the federal
government provides for that too
that's a bleak life i'd be crying too if
that were my life
what is this woman so afraid of
there are a lot of people like this who
believe know that
the supreme court the supreme court
should not have a huge effect on your
life
if it is something has gone wrong both
in politics and
in your personal life speaking of crazy
people by the way speaking of people who
are
kind of reacting in a poor way to the
fundamental changes that have gone on in
society
i can't close the show today without
getting to this very important headline
mother who realized she was gay at the
same time as
her husband came out as transgender
says they're happier than ever as a
lesbian couple
so let's uh let me see i think i need an
advanced degree to understand that
headline but
jenny who's 37 and sarah who's 38
revealed to each other on the same night
that sarah who used to be sean
told her meaning his wife of 15 years
jenny
that she meaning he was transgender
immediately after that
jenny told her husband that's okay i
think i'm gay
now that seems a little too convenient
for me i don't look i don't
pretend to know the particular situation
of this family
but what what the husband comes out and
says i
i'm a woman and that would seem to be a
threat to the family
and so it does seem a little convenient
for the wife then to be like oh no
that's cool i'm a lesbian
can we stay married please and i guess
they're going to stay married and
they've got kids and
it's actually i mean it's a hilarious
story if if you were able to separate
the
actual human suffering from it but it's
kind of a sad story when you realize
that they've got kids and
this is not this is not going to turn
out well
but what this really means right i don't
know if this guy's had surgery or
anything like that but
nothing really has changed right still a
guy
married to his wife he just he just
wears dresses sometimes
that's the big change but there's a lot
of confusion
around what is essentially not that big
of a shift
how do we get to that i mean it's a kind
of funny tabloid story and we can laugh
about it and they've always been
weird things that have happened in life
but
what's changed is that that is now
mainstream
right the difference is that's not just
a sideshow at a circus that is now the
mainstream and people believe that that
is ontologically possible for a man to
become a woman
simply by wishing it so and for the wife
then to just become a lesbian because
she's still married to a man which means
she's not a lesbian but the man is
pretending that he's a woman so she
thinks she is a lesbian
that's all delusional and yet we're
pretending that that is legitimate and
why because we have lost
a sense of of objective reality we've
lost a connection to objective reality
we've lost a sense of what we are for
what our society is for
what family is for the role of children
in that society
we got another one that one of the most
famous transgender
activists in the entire world jessica
yaniv
who is this big creepy dude who has had
very creepy interactions with children
and found himself
in a little bit of legal trouble because
of that well this guy
all he does is go around and sue people
for not giving in to his will so he very
famously put these
immigrant beauty salon workers out of
business
because he wanted them to give him a
brazilian
waxing and they wouldn't do that because
he's not a woman
and it's actually not you actually can't
give him a brazilian waxing
you have to give him what's called a
manzillion waxing which uses different
material because men and women are
different
and he was very upset that they wouldn't
do this so because
he was not able to expose himself to
these poor immigrant women
and these poor immigrant women weren't
willing to fondle his genitals
he sued them and put them out of
business so he's doing this again with a
beauty pageant
this guy has filed a complaint with the
human rights tribunal of ontario
because a female only beauty pageant
would not allow him to participate
because he's he's a man who has male
genitals
they were even willing to let him
participate if he
had the cosmetic surgery to make him
look more like a woman but he hasn't
even done that he's just a dude in a
dress
and so they said no you're not allowed
to do this so now he's filed a complaint
with the human rights tribunal of
ontario
he's been doing this for a very long
time and uh i was wondering
there are two options here one is this
guy should be sent to an insane asylum
so he can stop making a nuisance of
himself or all these poor people that
he's suing
and because he's obviously not
flourishing in life
so people who are this confused about
reality
should get special help so that's one
option but the other option i was just
thinking about this reading the story
about the beauty pageant after so many
stories involving this guy
maybe he's just a conservative troll you
ever think about that
conservatives pile on this guy jessica
yaniv a lot
what if he's just a conservative troll
i'm not saying that he is or that i
think he is
but if he were his behavior would be
indistinguishable from what it is now
because if men can really become women
simply by wishing it so
why the hell shouldn't that guy be in
the beauty pageant if men can
take it even further if men can simply
become women simply by wishing it so
why shouldn't he be allowed to get a
brazilian wax at the beauty parlor
he's a woman i'm sure the human rights
commission of ontario or whatever
organization he's filing with
believes and or at least states that men
can become women simply by wishing it so
our elite institutions in the united
states certainly believe that
federal government believes that the
universities believe that the
bureaucracy believes that
the mainstream media believe that they
all believe that so
why shouldn't that guy be allowed to get
his
brazilian wax i don't know this is this
is one of these instances of uh you know
providence perhaps or or of uh you know
our enemy becoming our friend or of uh
silver lining in a storm cloud
i think this guy is making a more
conservative argument than
just about anybody else anyone who could
state it explicitly because he's showing
the absurdity of a lot of these claims
these women in bathtubs with their
videos on tick tock are showing the
absurdity of the left
much better than than any conservative
who's trying to make arguments we'd like
to make recent arguments
but they are showing it in many ways and
i do think that
showing going out there doing i do think
this is going to be the decisive factor
in the campaign i
i don't believe i'm sorry to say i'm
glad tucker got a great scoop and it was
a great interview and
it's cool that he did it and it provides
more context for for those of us who
don't like biden
but i don't think that
these kind of reasoned nuanced arguments
about joe biden's corruption or anything
else
is going to win the presidential race i
think this race is all about
doing going out actually hitting the
campaign trail
talking to people showing in your
behavior the kind of society that you
want to have
and that's what they're doing you know
mike pence a lot of his staff the other
day was infected with coronavirus
and so there was some question as to
whether or not he would jump off of the
campaign trail
and he said no i'm going to keep
campaigning
i am going to keep going out there as he
damn well should
but the the experts tell you not to well
i don't care about the experts
i'm not i am not ruled by the experts
so i am going to keep campaigning
and that's that that's what they've got
to do this is not a persuasion campaign
this is a get out the vote campaign
nobody cares about joe biden's
corruption
go on and get at the vote now before we
go i do have to address one issue people
have written in asking about this
which is pope francis's confusing
comments on civil unions
i don't know if you saw this it was
reported in the newspapers that
pope francis is now embracing laws for
civil unions
which is just a sort of euphemism for
redefining marriage to include
monogamous same-sex couples but not
other
types of couples not polygamous couples
not right but it's this very narrow way
and they're saying it's a human right
now in certain places
so does pope francis support civil
unions the catholic church cannot
support civil unions as far as i can
tell obviously
uh you know i'm not a canon law expert
but that would appear to be the case
so what happens here well pope francis
has said in the past back when he was
cardinal bergoglio in argentina
he said that the redefinition of
marriage
is it's not a matter of irrational
animus it's not a matter of hatred
it's not a matter of i don't like this
type of person or this type of person
it's a
it's a fundamental change to the order
of society and of politics and it has a
spiritual dimension he said
it's no mere bill but rather a
machination of the father of lies that
seeks to deceive and confuse the
children of god
from the very beginning this this debate
over gay marriage or
civil unions or whatever has been
pushed by the left as a matter of rights
and a matter of hatred and you know if
you don't
want to fundamentally change the
definition of marriage that has existed
everywhere for all of human history
which though it has
had some details changed has always
involved sexual difference the union of
husbands and wives
if you don't want to fundamentally
redefine that then you hate gay people
right you do that's the only conclusion
right uh i don't think so that
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
but that that was a successful argument
they did they were able to frame it as a
question of rights rather than merely
a question of definitions what they
actually did to use the technical term
is beg the question
they assumed their own conclusions
namely that marriage
could be a union without sexual
difference and then
because they had defined it that way
they said that everyone has to have that
right
so what did pope francis say i don't
know what pope francis said the vatican
is coming out and in some ways disputing
his comments and saying he was misquoted
he was misinterpreted
papa francesco is always a
misinterpreted but for some reason he
keeps
talking to all of these a bad
journalists so
my only conclusion on this is the
teaching of the catholic church
can the dogma of the catholic church
cannot change
fundamental teachings cannot change
the pope's role is to explicate teaching
to develop teaching to deepen it perhaps
but can't contradict the teaching
of the church popes are fallible except
when they are infallible people hear
about papal infallibility
and they say that everything the pope
says must be true if the pope says two
plus two equals five it has to be true
that's now what papal infallibility
means
papal infallibility has been invoked i
believe two times in the history of the
catholic church
so the pope is is fallible except when
he's infallible and just as a general
rule i'm not even just
talking about francis specifically just
as a general rule sometimes the good
lord gives us
bad popes and this has happened many
times and
by the way it's perfectly acceptable i
know some more trad
conservative catholics are saying we're
not allowed to criticize the pope here
criticism of the pope is a long-standing
tradition in the catholic church
dante put two popes in hell with their
heads in dirt and flames burning the
soles of their feet
so this has been going on for a very
long time
i don't think we need to rush to
judgment i don't think we need to be
needlessly
harsh in our criticism but we can be
clear about it
and i just wouldn't
i wouldn't worry so much i wouldn't
agonize over every single statement as
though
that by virtue of the pope's segment
became gospel truth because the pope
has the the particular responsibility to
declare gospel truth but he cannot
contradict it all right that's our show
i'm michael nolan the michael knowles
show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you